protesters in moniwa in central myanmar
shelter as the security services advance
but there's little they can do in the
face of the onslaught
several of these protesters were shot in
the head
in mandalay doctors came out at dawn to
protest
their express intention to avoid a
confrontation with security forces
as they marched and chanted for a return
to democracy
but a crackdown came later in the day
the rider on this motorbike
narrowly avoids being shot as the police
moved into ang pinley district
in east mandalay as protesters shelter
behind
sandbags it's clear they've prepared
armed with slingshots fireworks and
petrol bombs they're trying to fight
back
to give themselves time to escape
but resistance is almost futile against
myanmar's armed forces
some cracks have appeared however
several groups of police fled across the
border into india
rather than open fire on their own
people
after reaching misarab we feel safe but
we heard from some sources that the
indian army was searching for us and
wanted to send us back to myanmar
we are not 100 safe here now they must
live in hiding
scared they could be sent home and they
offer a chilling insight
into the orders of those enforcing the
crackdown
we would be ordered to arrest beat
torture the protester
so we have no choice but to leave our
country
outside myanmar nationals living
overseas are keen to show their support
more than a thousand students and
workers gathered in taiwan
to commemorate those who have died but
at this stage
they can do little more than watch as
their homeland
appears to implode tony cheng al jazeera
[Music]